I can't believe that that my sweet
husband is a visible he's a movie star
on the brink of disaster mr. and mrs.
Chris Chris and take you to be my wedded
husband my wedded husband
yeah remember Kim Kardashian and Kris
Humphries they tied the knot with a
televised wedding in 2011 less than a
year after they started dating her she
later
but the split was pretty shocking
mostly because Kim filed for divorce
just 72 days after the I Do's
I thought with him and now my feelings
have changed you don't think I feel bad
that I invited all these people did this
huge wedding and it blew everyone out I
wasted everyone's time
you know I wasted everyone's money and
we said everyone's everything and I feel
bad you don't think I feel bad
I know what you are see Robert Pattinson
and Kristen Stewart met on the set of
Twilight's in 2008 and the chemistry was
instant I'm not afraid
[Music]
but after Kristen and her snow-white
director Rupert Sanders shocked the
world with their affair in 2012 things
were never quite the same
Robson tried to make it work but
eventually split in May 2013 though
these days they seemed to be on good
terms we were together for years that
was like my first you know hey love yeah
I mean like I was super in love with my
high school boyfriend so me and Rob were
like a little older and it was just like
go Gong but he's a charming guy he's
really one at fault row and Chris Martin
first met at a Coldplay concert in 2002
and then tied the knot in a secret
ceremony in December 2003 the pair then
had two kids together Apple in 2004 and
Moses in 2006 so yeah it was pretty
shocking when Gweneth announced they
were consciously uncoupling in 2014
though she vowed they would co-parent I
acknowledge that we've done it in kind
of an unorthodox way but it's working
for us and honestly they've made it work
Chris is now dating Dakota Johnson while
Gweneth is remarried to Brad Falchuk
it's been really a process to get to the
point where we can all be together and
luckily I have a deeply loving
ex-husband who's very open minded and
we've been able to create something you
know it's for the kids if you don't want
your kids to suffer obviously if I could
have you know stayed married to the
father of my kids that's kind of the
dream and but it didn't work out for me
so you know you have to adapt
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Brad Pitt and Angelina Jolie met while
filming mr. and mrs. Smith in 2004
while Brad was still married to Jen
Aniston congratulations on your second
year anniversary that's coming up you
plan yeah a lot of plans Brad and Jen
split in 2005 and Brangelina was born
going public as a couple that same year
together they share six kids three
biological children Shiloh and twins
Vivian and Knox adopted son pax
and Brad also became a stepdad to
Angie's previously adopted kids Maddox
and Sahara after nearly 10 years
together they Wed in 2014 do I trust one
of my wife and then they really
surprised everyone when Angie filed for
divorce in September 2016 but it's clear
the kiddos come first you know moms
everywhere are saying how the heck does
she do that and make it look so easy
wrangling them all and having they
wrangle me honestly they're they're more
together as the hora is the most
organized in the family she looked
gorgeous that dressed yet on this
beautiful
[Music]
this is a big step Chris Pratt and Donna
Ferris met on the set of take me home
tonight in 2007 in 2008 they got engaged
and then married in 2009 we're so lucky
that we kind of had the same sense of
humor
the couples seemed to have it all
especially humor our motto is eye on the
prize they welcomed their son Jack in
2012 and when they announced their split
in 2017 the fans were taken aback
doesn't only look amazing it was a
really easy pick on this one it's so
nice plunging neckline very very sexy
he's a good man we're talking all about
me and it's his career
ahna has since moved on with
cinematographer Michael Barrett and
Chris Mary Katherine Schwarzenegger in
2019
[Music]
she just she's a really good person and
she brings out the best in Justin Bieber
and Selena Gomez are this generation's
Britney Spears and Justin Timberlake
they started dating in 2010 and made
their red carpet debut at the 2011
Vanity Fair Oscar party after years of
being on again and off again they
briefly reunited in 2018 but just a
couple months later he was hanging out
with now wife Haley who he proposed to
just months after he and Selena broke up
while neither has talked publicly about
the split Justin did tell et this in
2015 I'd love to know what she thinks
about your she'd love it I had her album
I heard a couple songs did you like it
yeah I think she's great she's super
talented
[Music]
Jenna Dewan and Channing Tatum met on
the set of step up in 2006 you know on
the set we had such a great time I mean
it was like instant chemistry for the
two of us they got engaged in 2008 and
married in 2009 they welcomed their
daughter Everly in 2013 but five years
later in 2018 they announced their split
Channing has moved on with Jessie J
while Jenna is expecting a baby with
boyfriend Steve Kazee
I mean you know it's mind blowing the
whole thing watching a child grow inside
of a human has been like the most
amazing experience so far but it's good
I'm trying to try to just stay calm and
and not panic can't just like let it all
happen
[Music]